now since everything is nurtured then
this is an accent like
crazy d you would look the way you look
because that's genetic
yeah of course you wouldn't have the
catholic tattoos because that's an old
world
you're going to be more of a buddhist
slash if i do get a tattoo it's going to
be like a little chinese symbol or it's
going to be like a ladder
yeah that goes to like eternity and
towards my heart but make no mistake
we're all kind of the same it's like
that you grew up in richwood
you're a richwood kid that's why you say
unfortunately but if you were from san
francisco you'd be like hi
you'd get on stage you go hi guys my
name is chrissy d
[ __ ] i'm from a montessori school in
the middle of san francisco let's talk
about this golden gate bridge for a
second
it's crazy isn't the golden gate bridge
amazing
guys do you know what i hate i hate when
people come into a door and they say hi
sir it's like you're assuming gender
yeah don't do it yeah we're just and
listen let me tell you something yeah
if you're in any big city here's gas
pipe chrissy dick yeah
if you're in any you always call it gas
pipe but it's [ __ ] steel pipe
chrissy yeah
if you're in any big city okay
especially new york city i know we got
fans from all over the world
um and when i mean all over the world i
mean you know the tri-state area you
know mainly just [ __ ] the five
boroughs
but um yeah we're like the jerky boys
yeah
chocolate boys were fun we got some
british fans we got australian fans we
got fans
[ __ ] worlds all over the [ __ ]
world the united states of america
if you're in any big city the truth is
there's so many people in this city
i don't need you to be over polite in a
[ __ ] store i don't need you to come
back can i help you with anything are
you freaking everything you can
are you waiting for just shut the [ __ ]
up yeah if i [ __ ] need something i'll
find it because guess what
i wouldn't be able to survive 34 years
in new york [ __ ] city
if i didn't know if i didn't know where
to go to get what i want i don't need
you
in a [ __ ] 10 by 10 foot store to
[ __ ] tell me where the coffee is i
know where the coffee is because guess
what the science is [ __ ] coffee
and that was steel pipe [ __ ] chrissy
drinks won't troll
it's just the [ __ ] hypocrisy of
people being nice like when you call
someone in verizon like anything is
there anything else that can help you
with today's like
i was just on the phone with you for
three and a half hours don't you think
if there was something else i would have
[ __ ] told you
stop just being a [ __ ] robot and
let's be real you [ __ ] call me
okay i'm get you asked me for help i'm
gonna help you i'm not gonna [ __ ]
suck your dick
to try to [ __ ] you know it's like shut
up lady just let me [ __ ] move around
the store please
and you know when anybody sneaker stores
clothing shows you come on do you need
some help
it's like you know what i was gonna buy
something but now the fact
you just invaded my personal space i'm
either gonna not get anything i'm gonna
steal something yeah that's what it is
steel pipe [ __ ] chrissy come get
yeah don't you hate when you go to the
sneaker store and they like kind of
hover over your shoulder
it's the worst that's my least favorite
it's always some indian dude because a
lot of those stores are owned by indian
guys yeah just everybody buddy you need
anything buddy i'm like come on man just
let me
dude you don't need to sell me on
anything i just hate the phoniness of
everything i really [ __ ] hate it all
chrissy's [ __ ] i [ __ ] hate it all
right we can't that's why you can't have
power yeah
no no no no no no no no okay we cannot
no power i
don't want listen i know i get rageful
but i can step back with it and i'm you
know pretty much a nice kid and i am
deep down a very gay kid
so i don't want to hurt anything and i
want to just you know i want to paint
and i
because to be honest with you i just
want to live in an empire where it's
okay for me for guys to swing dicks
around
and i could just grab a few seconds if i
want to if i you know whatever i want to
do i want to put a finger in the butt
it just doesn't matter there's no
judgment i could just suck a dick yeah
yeah yeah that that's the empire i want
and i you know me i just want to eat
sweets and listen to whitney that's just
what i want to do and also play
basketball
you know and do [ __ ] like that and talk
about state capitals that's all i want
to do
yeah but the truth of the matter is make
no mistake
make no mistake hashtag mnm make that
mistake
if i was given absolute power i would
100 percent
lose it quickly and burn the empire down
but out of kindness and goodness because
i would just
you know somebody would be able to
manipulate me and tell me
that you know and this i should i should
go alone
to this other far away nation because
you know they have nutella there
and they have you know um um all
different kinds of puerto rican men and
women
that i would think are hot and they play
whitney houston on repeat black and
white cookies
everybody's tits are made of black and
white cookies you could chew off other
people's nails
chew off other people yeah you can text
yeah you do whatever you want that just
give you new thumbs every time your
thumbs fall off from texting too much
you could just do that you're allowed to
text and drive do whatever you want yeah
and i would go alone that you would say
the only the only catches though
you can't bring your personal bodyguard
you have to come alone and then as soon
as i step foot off my
country i would be beheaded and lose
power that's me so i would lose it
either way now giannis
aka freddy feta cheese aka the robo
cheese
aka um katie lang before you continue
can i just say something real quick yeah
you got a strong [ __ ] jawline yeah
i was looking at you i'm like yo you
look like the cartoon american dad
yeah but you got a [ __ ] strong
jawline cuz yeah but then i got [ __ ]
tits like [ __ ] mom like the mom from
bobby's well you know
when you got a jawline like that but i
got super seeds all the other jello you
got going on yeah but make no mistake i
do got mashed potato tits yeah but i am
distracted by a [ __ ]
strong christopher reeves superman
american dad
[ __ ] jawline yeah no
so that's me with absolute power giannis
pompous with absolute power
make no mistake i know giannis at a very
deep
personal level and listen to me when i
tell you
this he is [ __ ] inherently evil i'm
an evil kid and the only reason and he
has a mean streak
and the only reason he doesn't kill
the head and drink the blood of anybody
that crosses him
is because of his fear of imprisonment
yeah and and
and the only reason why he's scared of
going to prison is then because he can't
read reuters news
sources that's the only reason he's
scared is because then he can't read
blogs and he can't
i think i love how you called it reuters
like like it's the plumbing company
reuters
what is reuters reuters
sometimes you trip over your own trash
yeah so because he doesn't have access
to the new york times and different
articles
and different um kind of feng shui sites
he would not want to go to prison and
that's the only reason why that's the
only thing
if you told him that i can you can get
the new york times and you can watch
um cnn on repeat and he can jerk off to
all [ __ ] wolf blitzers and anderson
cooper's you know magical points that
they make and
you know uh megan kelly and he if you
told him that he could rub his transpose
to all those liberal sites he would do
it and he would go to and he would have
no fear so it's a good thing
that he's not allowed to watch and read
those liberal sites in prison or else he
would go
but if we gave janus power no matt
he would start to concoct things up in
his head
and he would start to if you crossed him
you would be beheaded but you wouldn't
even be beheaded
quickly you would be beheaded slowly
depending on who you are you would take
a piece of your cervical vertebrae one
by one
you have seven cervical vertebrae in the
in your head that connect your head to
your neck
he would cut one out day by day that's a
good idea and just keep you alive
what he would also do is because make no
mistake what
he giannis had giannis feels that
um 16 year old girls are fair play
so
yeah whenever he says something so
[ __ ] wild he's he's trying to send me
to prison
just [ __ ] sweet swing listen go make
sure
you rate review us subscribe uh turn on
your notifications
get jiggy with it and go to
patreon.comridgeboys where things get
really wild